foreign
this is the first time since april of
2020 the iranians have done this and to
talk more about what this means and put
it into context of the talks here in
vienna i'm joined now by mohammed
morandi
mr mandy can you tell us first
specifically this launch into space was
it part of iran's ballistic missile
program or is it part of the space
program are they very much separate or
intertwined and also can you tell us why
would the iranians decide to do this at
this juncture
it's a part of iran's space program and
iran's had a space program for quite a
long time it's sent satellites into
orbit
on a number of occasions it's over 10
years since iran sent its first
satellite into space
i think it's pretty clear that
the iranians are going to continue
with business as usual whether it's
regards to its space program or even its
missile ballistic missile technology we
saw iran's military maneuvers just
carried out a few days ago that was
obviously a message to the united states
and to the israelis that any military
conflict would lead to devastating
consequences in other words those
maneuvers were carried out to prevent
war
but
when the iranians believe that when the
united states is trying to prevent iran
from importing even medicine and when
the europeans assist the united states
in banning
such imports then iran has to become
self-sufficient
you